c'est la force de gravitation qui
maintient autour de la terre les nuages
et l'air dans lequel il flotte l'air
impalpable et invisible à ce point
omniprésent qu'on finit par en oublier
l'existence l'air sans lequel pourtant
les graines et les insectes les oiseaux
et les hommes serait incapable de
s'arracher à l'attraction terrestre
les graines de pissenlit flotte parce
que le moindre souffle de vent peu les
soulever et elle retourne très lentement
car leur corps leurs pieds à l'air comme
un parachute
c'est ainsi qu'elle traverse les plus
vaste océan pour atterrir sur les îles
les plus lointaines les graines de
pollen sont si petites que la présence
de duvet n'est pas nécessaire pour les
maintenir dans l'air les inégalités
microscopique de leurs surfaces sont
suffisantes les sports expulsés par la
vesse de loup sont encore plus petits le
moindre souffle les éparpillés aux
alentours par dizaines de millions comme
de la fumée
la file en dhr ou fils de la vierge qui
parfois recouvre les prêts est
l'équivalent animal des graines
duveteuse elle est produite par des
milliers de petites araignées
dès leur naissance ces araignées grimpe
au sommet des tiges d'herbe ou sur de
petits tas de gravier
elles dirigent leur abdomen vers le haut
et à partir de leurs glandes filière
elles produisent un fil de soie très fin
à mesure que celui-ci s'allonge le vent
l'emportent
à un moment donné la petite araignée se
retourne elle saisit le fil avec ses
pattes antérieures et se laisse emporter
par lui seul les plus petits les plus
légers des animaux et des plantes
peuvent défier les lois de la gravité de
cette façon beaucoup de grain sont trop
lourde pour être ainsi transportées par
le vent
même si elles sont très douteuse par
contre celles qui sont produites au
sommet d'un arbre élevés peuvent au
contraire exploiter la gravitation
s'égrènent ci qui pousse dans la jungle
du venezuela possède des ailettes conçu
de telle façon que lorsqu'elle tombe de
l'arbre et le tournoi leur descente et
ralentit et le vent peut les entraîner à
une certaine distance de l'arbre dont
elles proviennent
certains animaux comme ceux gecko volant
du sud est asiatique peuvent parvenir un
résultat comparable grâce à des orteils
palmer qui leur permettent d'amortir la
vitesse de leur chute
dans la même forêt un autre les a
réussies a plané lui aussi en étirant de
véritables zèle de pau à partir de ses
flancs mais le champion de cet exercice
est cet écureuil volant dans les normes
manteau de pau pendante constitue un
véritable parachute en vol horizontal
il peut même faire mieux tout comme cela
se produit sur les ailes d'un avion
lorsque l'air attaque le bord frontale
de son manteau tendu la pression se
réduit sur la surface supérieure de
celui-ci et l'écureuil peut alors
légèrement s'est levé toutes ces
créatures planante peuvent contrôler
leur direction mais elles sont
généralement incapables de se propulser
très haut
paradoxalement c'est plus près du sol
dans la végétation des hautes herbes que
l'on trouve les créatures qui ont de
véritables aptitudes au vol le mouvement
le plus exigeant et le décollage
l'insecte doit se hisser dans l'air à la
seule force de ses muscles par un
balayage circulaire de cl il augmente
rapidement la pression sur lui et se
trouve ainsi aspiré vers le haut
des insectes plus grands comme les
sauterelles accentue cet effet par un
bon puissant au moment de quitter le sol
l'envol des oiseaux beaucoup plus lourd
réclame plus d'énergie encore les
oiseaux utilisent également leur patte
musclées pour soulager le travail de
leurs ailes ils sautent ils s'élancent
dans l'air
des oiseaux les plus grands pour
décoller doivent augmenter la vitesse du
courant d'air par dessus leur zèle ils
ne peuvent s'envoler sans avoir pris de
la vitesse en s'appuyant sur le sol ou
sur l'eau
zac te ment comme le fer n'avions
décollage
une fois dans l'air les animaux volants
de toutes sortes pénètre un
environnement complètement différent et
il exploite à fond les demoiselles
trouvent leur nourriture dans l'air elle
si un couple et même elle s'y bat
ce sphinx dépose ses oeufs sur les
fleurs tout en volant car il est trop
lourd pour s'y poser
il s'alimente également en vol
stationnaire en face de la fleur dont il
suce le nectar avec une trompe filiforme
ce colibri l'eucalyptus d'hélène est
encore plus petit que le sphinx
il a cette même aptitude à battre des
ailes jusqu'à 80 fois par seconde pour
se maintenir en l'air quasi immobile
pendant qu'il boit dans le calice les
fleurs
les ailes des oiseaux sont mieux adaptés
que celle des insectes car leur plume
s'ajuste de manière idéale glissant
aisément les unes sur les autres
permettant de varier la forme et la
surface de cll peuvent de la sorte c'est
tendre largement lorsqu elle s'abaisse
puis pendant le mouvement ascendant se
rétrécir pour offrir moins de résistance
à l'air
la réduction de la pression de l'air sur
la surface des ailes qui facilite
l'élévation peut être parfaitement
observée au ralenti car elle a pour
effet d'aspirer les petites plumes vers
le haut l'albatros est expert dans l'art
de s'élever en s'appuyant sur les
courants ascendants
là encore la réduction de la pression
produite lorsque l'air passe sur les
ailes déployées de l'oiseau entraîne un
eris mandé plus lorsqu'il doit à voyager
contre le vent l'albatros descend près
de la surface de l'eau car les vagues
diminue la force de la brise
les falaises sont des lieux de
prédilection pour les planeurs comme
l'albatros elle dévie vers le haut le
vent venant du large et permettent ainsi
aux oiseaux de décoller aisément ou de
rester comme suspendue en l'air pendant
des heures dans ces courants ascendants
la chaleur peut permettre aussi de
s'élever dans l'air dans une
montgolfière cette chaleur est produite
par des becs de gaz et l'air ascendant
est si puissant qu'il permet d'entraîner
vers le ciel une lourde nacelle et
plusieurs passagers nous sommes en
afrique et nous nous dirigeons vers les
grandes plaines à gibier du serengeti
alors que le soleil réchauffe la terre
d'autres courants d'air chaud se forme
naturellement au dessus des blocs de
rochers ou de contenu qui plutôt que
d'absorber les rayons du soleil les
réfléchissent cette ascendance thermique
est particulièrement apprécié des
vautours
ces grands oiseaux possède des ailes à
leurs mesures pénibles à mettre en
mouvement
le matin les oiseaux se contente de
voleter d'un arbre bas à l'autre ils
attendent que la terre se réchauffe
à présent un vautour va venir nous
rejoindre
à rochers qui affleurent est en train de
s'échauffer au soleil l'air au dessus de
lui va s'élever et c'est exactement ce
dont a besoin le vautour pour s'envoler
facilement
les vautours grimpe toujours davantage
utilisant les courants thermiques pour
scruter sans effort la plaine où
défilent la plus grande concentration de
bétail du monde avant la nuit
un gnou au moins aura été la victime des
prédateurs les vautours ont maintenant
pris leur essor à plusieurs centaines de
mètres d'altitude ils peuvent rapidement
décelé la présence d'un animal mort
si c'est le cas il plonge vers le sol
dès qu'un oiseau a repéré une carcasse
des douzaines d'autres arrivent
ceux ci sont des vautours de taille
moyenne des vautours de rupel ou des
vautours à dos blanc mais parmi eux se
trouve l'un des plus grands des vautours
africain le vautour nubien dans ces
montagnes africaine comme dans certains
autres d'asie et d'europe vit une espèce
de vautours le gypaète barbu qui a un
mode d'alimentation très particulier il
se nourrit non seulement deux mois mais
des eaux humaine et pour cela il utilise
une technique singulière
il porte tout d'abord ces eaux jusqu'à
un véritable atelier c'est un rocher
dénudé loiseau le choisit proche du bord
de la falaise
ainsi le vautour pourra s'envoler plus
aisément s'il doit transporter à un os
très lourd
il ne lui reste maintenant qu'à prendre
de l'altitude et a lâché son fardeau sur
le rocher enclume où il va se briser en
menus morceaux
certains grands corbeaux procède de la
même manière mais généralement avec
beaucoup moins de discernement quant au
choix du terrain maintenant il ne reste
plus aux gypaète qu'à consommer son
repas
les chouettes ont également des ailes
très développé mais pour une autre
raison
leur grande porte ans permet à la
chouette de ne pas devoir les battre
bruyamment et c'est vital pour un animal
qui s'il veut atteindre ses proies
nocturne doigt les approcher dans le
plus grand silence
ces plumes sont même bordé d'un duvet
très doux qui leur sert en quelque sorte
de silencieux bien que les chouettes
chasse après la tombée de la nuit
elle s'oriente grâce à la grande acuité
de leurs vues et leur vol silence eu
leur permet de déceler le moindre
crissement révélant la présence de
campagnols de souris quand les nuits
sont complètement noir même une chouette
ne peut cependant s'y orienter ses nuits
là appartiennent aux seuls chauve souris
elles sont capables de se diriger dans
l'obscurité totale
elle dispose d'une sorte de sonar
naturelles elles poussent ceux décrits
dans la gamme des ultrasons et ce guide
sur les échos killer proviennent en
retour elles sont à droite au point de
gober une mouche en plein vol
les oiseaux ont une telle maîtrise de
l'air et une telle capacité à rester en
vol pendant des journées entières qu'ils
sont devenus les plus grands voyageurs
du monde animal au dessus de panama en
octobre et en novembre
on peut en observer des nuées
impressionnante
les faucons et les vautours aura ou
cattaert fuyant l'arrivée de l'hiver
s'envole pour un séjour de quelques mois
plus au sud
à mesure que le temps se réchauffe il
trouve les courants thermiques qui leur
permettent d'atteindre l'altitude
nécessaires pour effectuer leurs vols
moyennant un minimum d'effort les
oiseaux ne sont pas les seuls à
accomplir ses immenses parcours
intercontinentaux aussi incroyable que
cela paraisse des créatures en apparence
très frêle peuvent en faire autant
des insectes s'envolent ainsi avec une
volonté tenace sur la trace des oiseaux
migrateurs les plus endurants ces
papillons monarques sont nés en automne
dans les bois d'amérique du nord
ils viennent d'arriver à mexico après un
voyage extraordinaire de plus de trois
mille kilomètres il se reposeront ici
quelques mois
ensuite ils effectueront le voyage du
retour se nourrissant et s'accouplant en
vol finalement quelques uns rejoindront
les bois du renaissance ainsi la terre
est survolées d'itinéraires d'animaux
migrateurs aux amériques la plupart
transitent par panama
bien que quelques audacieux choisissent
les tables des caraïbes
ces trajets peuvent atteindre des
milliers de kilomètres l'enveloppent
atmosphérique elle n'a que huit
kilomètres d'épaisseur
c'est une altitude que l'on peut
atteindre en montgolfière mieux équipée
toutefois que celle utilisée
précédemment en afrique car à cette
hauteur un système d'approvisionnement
en oxygène est nécessaire
maintenant nous sommes très près des
limites de cette atmosphère qui
enveloppe la planète
c'est à cette altitude que se produise
que se détermine les variations
météorologiques le temps qu'il fait à la
surface de la terre se joue ici dans la
haute atmosphère
les molécules d'eau s'évaporant de la
surface des mers et des lacs par la
chaleur du soleil ainsi que celles
produites par les plantes sous forme de
vapeur s'élève de la surface de la terre
et en même temps se refroidit se
condensent pour former des nuages de
gouttelettes
déplacer au gré des vents ces nuages
s'évapore et se re condense se forme et
se reforment les plus grandes
perturbations de l'atmosphère sont dues
à de gigantesques courants thermiques
provoqué par le soleil dans un ciel
chargé d'humidité les molécules d'eau à
l'intérieur des nuages se condensent
pour former des gouttelettes de plus en
plus grande
l'air s'élève rapidement et les
maintient suspendu à l'intérieur des
nuages
finalement leur poids les entraîne sous
forme de pluies torrentielles
un orage tel que celui ci peut apporter
la mort et la destruction
il peut aussi apporter la vie car les
pluies qui l'engendrent sont distillées
par le soleil à partir de la surface des
océans
ces pluies sont donc constitué d'eau
fraîche non salées indispensable à toute
forme d'existence sur la tête